مشاهد جميله هنا في لندن وحول المملكه
المتحده بعد سقوط كثيف الثلوج خلال ال 24
ساعه الاخيره ولكن صاحبت معها اضطرابات
شديده لحركه النقل والعمل في البلاد
عده مطارات من بينها مانشستر الغت العديد
من الرحلات ومطارات هيثرى وجع تويك اعلنت
عن تاخير او تاجيل العشرات من الرحلات
خدمه القطارات ايضا المتوقفه في انحاء
عديده من البلاد وهنا في لندن مترو
الانفاق يشهد تعطيلا شديدا اغلب الخطوط
فيها تعليق الخدمه او اغلاق تام لبعض
المحطات وفي الوقت نفسه افضل الشبكه
الوطنيه البريطانيه بلاغا لتهيئتي مصنعه
فحم الشتويين ضمن خطه طوارئ ان لطمنت
الناس بشان امدادات الطاقه
من نقص شديد في امدادات الكهرباء من دون
ان تؤكد ما اذا كانت البلاد ستحتاج اليهما
كما تسبب ثلج في بعض الحوادث من بينها حدث
سقوط اربعه اطفال في بحيره جليد في منطقه
برمينجهام مساء الاربعاء وفي وقت لاحق
اكدت الشرطه ان تلاته من الاطفال فرغوا
الحياه فيما بقى الرابع في حاله حرجه
وستحذيرات من السلطات بتوخي الحذر مع
استمرار موجه البرد لبدعه ايام كارينا
كامل العربيه